Kim Kardashian freaks out over mom kris
Jenner's look like wax figure which she
keeps at her house I'm really freaking
out during chrises annual holiday dinner
party with family friends Chrissy Teigen
and John Legend Kim came face to face
with her mom's waxy twin well that's so
you could visit with me and not have to
listen to me talk to you Hollywood Wax
Museum they made one for me I can't even
tell you how creepy and amazing this is
like it's exact down to the little mark
she has like everything about it you
guys this is her exact hairline Chrissy
was even mesmerised by the mannequin
it's never a dull moment
Perez isn't the only one with a
doppelganger all of her daughters have
several around the globe I love that
Kim received her first figure in 2010
and it dawned and availa hair dress
of course my heart and soul the reality
stars figure in England lets you take a
selfie with it it's always so much fun I
feel like it's like old times
Chris's daughter Kendall has also got a
few but the one on display in England
matches her to a tee Kylie Jenner
unveiled her wax figure in 2017 she
donated the custom balm on gown she wore
for her debut at the 2016 Met Gala the
same dress that left her legs scratched
up cute over here
both Chloe and Courtney have some of
their own as well which are on display
in New York and Las Vegas this is insane
but nothing beats Chris's creepy copy
and literally knew I was coming up here
and I still got startled seeing this her
wax figure to have just sitting on her
bar like in
[Music]
Wow
[Music]